[Music]
hi I'm Ashley Fenella I'm an engineer in
the research and AI group now we're
working on a platform that's for doing
systems like this this is one of the
applications it's a mobile directions
robot we have it in building 99 normally
with the building maps there and you can
ask it to take you to conference rooms
to people's offices it can give people a
tour it's built using this platform
called the platform for situated
intelligence and lots of componentry
that's in place already for some of the
best human perception components and
there's a bridge to Ross for using some
of the low-level control components
there the research interest is
essentially in adding more social
awareness to systems like this so things
like understanding multi-party
engagement so for example a group of
people walks up to the robot it needs to
understand whether the people are
talking to each other or if they're
talking to the robot when is a good time
to interrupt and things like that also
classifying human activities so they can
make decisions based on that and some
more socially appropriate navigation
like staying to the right in hallways
boarding elevators properly not cutting
between people if they're talking and
things like that that's the basic idea
it's a platform for further social
robotics research Thanks